[Música]
y seguimos en directo América con
nuestra segunda invitada del día vamos a
bienvenida a Susana mangana directora de
la cátedra del islam de la Universidad
Católica de Uruguay también analista
política internacional
Susana Bueno un gusto saludarla
nuevamente y que nos acompañe en directo
América de France 24 Quisiera saber su
opinión ante todo esto que está pasando
y después desmenuzar todo lo que nos
digamos
donde me encuentro ahora en el norte de
España
estas horas temen nuevos bombardeos de
la Aviación rusa con lo cual lo que
siento en estos momentos Raúl haciéndolo
muy corto es tristeza y bastante
frustración porque yo creo que se
Tendría que haber evitado este tipo de
agresión rusa
y la mañana cómo hubiéramos podido
evitar todo esto que está ocurriendo
porque la vida diplomática pues no pasó
el presidente Emmanuel macron lideró
como este gran acción diplomática
también otros presidentes visitaron al
mandatario ruso Vladimir Putin y nada
ocurrió es que digamos que también
hablando con otros analistas Susana
decían que esto no se planea tampoco de
la noche a la mañana digamos que Rusia
le mintió de alguna manera la comunidad
internacional y a todo el mundo diciendo
que no quería invasión y en el momento
entre comillas menos pensado porque
también la noche anterior eh lo había ya
anunciado el jefe del pentágono que iba
a ser la invasión y en efecto ocurrió
Entonces a qué está jugando Rusia qué
está pasando Susana
Bueno yo creo que realmente como tú
dices esto no se organiza no es orquesta
de un día para el otro y las palabras se
las lleva como tú sabes Raúl el viento
es decir hace ya muchos años Que Putin y
tiene una estrategia geopolítica que
resulta una amenaza Clara y evidente
para los países bálticos para letonia
lituania y Estonia pero también para
países de Europa
y también diplomáticos jóvenes de
moldovia y otras regiones y otros países
que otro era fueran parte de lo que era
la unión soviética que sienten esa
amenaza muy real y que creo que tanto
Naciones Unidas como sus organismos y
también por supuesto la diplomacia
europea no tomó en serio las acciones de
un Putin que quiere devolver grandeza a
Rusia a través de mostrar su músculo
militar tal como ha hecho en Ucrania
desde el 2014 recordemos que él ha
estado enviando tropas un día sí y al
otro también desde
Qué significa milicias Pro rusas de
ciudadanos que nacen que crecen que se
benefician de los servicios que brinda
Ucrania en el este del país y que ahora
dicen quiero ser ruso porque me siento
más cómodo con la lengua los lazos
históricos y culturales de Rusia y Rusia
unilateralmente el lunes pasado firma la
independencia y el reconocimiento a las
milicias separatistas
claramente no solo nos ha estado
mintiendo sino que se Estaba preparando
esto por lo menos desde hace 8 años por
eso es inaceptable la inoperancia la
ineficacia de la diplomacia y del Real
politic de las potencias occidentales
que han jugado al gato y al ratón con el
señor Putin y desde luego Raúl mi
opinión personal es que se nota mucho la
ausencia de jefes con un liderazgo
carismático y claro en Europa como tenía
Angela Merkel de Alemania creo que
Johnson está muy acorralado y Atrapado
por sus propios desastres en Reino Unido
y desde luego macron no ha estado a la
altura de la situación lo intenta pero
resulta no creíble también para el
presidente Putin que ha seguido
avanzando ante los titubeos de un
presidente
Susana hablabas de también un
protagonista importante y ha sido lo que
fue el gobierno durante 16 años de la
canciller Ángela Merkel también en su
gobierno se gestó todo este proyecto del
gasoducto North Stream 2 la sanción más
dura que ahora el gobierno del canciller
Olaf Shoes tomó fue paralizar digamos
este proyecto Pero igual el 1 sigue
funcionando digamos que Merkel se
imaginaba una situación así
para está dependencia del gas de Europa
por parte de Rusia
al presidente Obama de que realmente no
tenía que atacar al régimen de bazar la
salla y vemos el desastre en que se ha
convertido ese conflicto sin fin en
Siria ha seguido avanzando hacia el
Mediterráneo una zona geográficamente no
le es entorno próximo es decir está
presente en Libia está presente también
no solo en el norte de África en el
Mediterráneo donde hay prospección y
explotación gasífera sino que también ha
avanzado en su relacionamiento con
países africanos es decir hace ya mucho
tiempo
mostrando también la hilacha podríamos
decir en materia Geo estratégica y
geopolítica pero sobre todo hay un punto
de fricción con la Unión Europea que es
la gran perdedora ahora con esta
invasión a Ucrania porque no se lo puede
llamar de otra forma No son fuerzas de
mantenimiento de la Paz como él intenta
decir sino que son fuerzas militares que
están invadiendo Ucrania un territorio
soberano
tenía sus intereses sobre todo
económicos dependiente también del gas
que importaba y sigue importando de
Rusia ahora bien Yo creo que se ha
mostrado ahí una carencia toda vez que
no está Merkel para la negociación para
la diplomacia que ha sido muy ineficaz
Fíjate que llevamos semanas de
negociaciones
y las cancillerías europeas y Finalmente
nos ha mentido a todos a los europeos
también y por eso lo digo con profunda
tristeza realmente quedo sobrecogida por
la falta de interés que percibo en la
población europea estando aquí en España
pero que es algo extensible a Gran
Bretaña a Francia donde se habla mucho
más de la pandemia de lo que es la
posibilidad de una guerra que hoy se se
hace cierta a las puertas de Europa Raúl
y ya hablamos eso Susana Pero entonces
en esa orden de ideas que estábamos
conversando los intereses económicos de
estas potencias europeas de los países
europeos permitieron que todo esto
estallara en sus narices permitieron que
todo esto llegara a este punto digamos
que de alguna manera se le pudo salir de
las manos y no contaban Realmente si iba
a cumplir sus intereses reales que los
estamos viendo ahora a Susana
un cálculo de errores
o sea un error de cálculo estratégico
más bien Es decir que realmente creyeron
que Putin no iba a concretar esa amenaza
Y claro que lo ha hecho es decir yo creo
que Putin ha ido avanzando toda vez que
se la ha dejado hacer desde la Unión
Europea que ya sabemos que no hay
consenso que realmente siempre reacción
ante este tipo de conflictos bélicos
tenemos varios antecedentes desde la
época de los balcanes y la
desintegración de la unión Perdón
yo creo que pasando por otros conflictos
como el mencioné antes de Siria pero
también ha avanzado porque creo que va y
de natitudeado con el propio Putin
habría que preguntarse si esto hubiera
ocurrido en caso de haber estado un
presidente con otra muy criticado a
nivel internacional pero que finalmente
tenía otro tipo de cercanía de empatía
con el presidente ruso la dependencia
económica más bien por la parte
energética sí de los recursos
energéticos de Rusia pero yo creo que
sobre todo lo que primaba hasta ahora en
la Euro intentar evitar este tipo de
conflictos bélicos porque tenemos otros
antecedentes tenemos por ejemplo la
agresión a chicoslovaquia tenemos la
agresión también en época del nazismo
Pero tenemos varias Guerras en Europa
más cercanas Incluso como fue el
traslado de tropas
diplomático de la negociación Pero no
pasa la acción Entonces esto realmente
es un precedente pésimo No creo que
Putin pueda extenderse mucho tiempo en
esta invasión a Ucrania pero ciertamente
salen muy perjudicados todos los
ciudadanos de Ucrania y por supuesto el
liderazgo europeo con una vez más ha
hecho aguas y hablemos de eso porque no
los quiero dejar de un lado realmente
los que sí sufren esta guerra y las
malas decisiones políticas como usted
también lo estaba mencionando son los
civiles la población civil la gente
sobre que vive en estas regiones a
fronterizas donde está de todo este
conflicto incluso ya las Naciones Unidas
ha pedido a los países fronterizos con
Ucrania que mantenga su frontera
abiertas para poder recibir a todas
estas personas que quieren ir de un
conflicto y que no quieren pues perder
familiares incluso perder su propia vida
es Susana que va a pasar Eh con esto sí
podemos ver también una una migración
masiva como la que vimos en la guerra de
de 2014 interna y también externa hacia
otros países europeos Susana
de hoy hora de la capital de Ucrania
hemos podido escuchar el testimonio de
personas ucranianas que tienen un
vínculo muy fuerte
digamos el temor la ansiedad y el miedo
que están sufriendo Cómo han tenido que
poner a sus ancianos a sus abuelos a sus
niños menores en autobuses para intentar
sacarlos de sus casas
lejanos y tenemos que recurrir a
bombardeos para poder solucionar este
tipo de diferentes yo creo que realmente
es indigno que tengamos que volver a ver
esas columnas de personas en esta
ocasión coches pero también otros que
han decidido que como va a haber atasco
si van a tener que pasar mucho tiempo en
la carretera temen bombardeo sobre esas
columnas esos vehículos que intenta
salir a apresuradamente hoy de algunas
de las ciudades y pueblos de kiev hacia
la frontera pero recordemos como tú
decías que los países vecinos no son
todos amistosos con Ucrania Bielorrusia
por ejemplo con un presidente como Lucas
5 totalmente alineado con Putin no va a
abrir la puerta
para luego castigarlos adentro tanto
como lo hace Putin en casa entonces
realmente es una situación tétrica y
creo que esto nos debe avergonzar a
todos como comunidad internacional pero
sobre todo nos hace reflexionar a mí por
lo menos sobre Qué tipo de líderes
políticos tenemos que han permitido que
se llega este estado de situación cuando
acabas de tener antes de mí has tenido
otros analistas que han hecho un
análisis un diagnóstico yo diría muy
cercano al que hago yo sobre la
situación y por tanto todo esto se podía
prever Es triste que tengan que pagar
los platos rotos de estos conflictos los
ciudadanos de a pie que realmente
peligrosos domicilios las escuelas de
sus hijos pero que además no saben si
mañana volverán a sus casas y las
encontrarán destruidas Entonces esto se
debiera tener que solucionar en esta
época en la que vivimos de otra manera
Raúl
completamente lamentable como usted lo
dice y realmente impactante también ver
esas imágenes de la gente tratando de
vivir de kiev la gente la de
preocupación con solamente un bolso
encima
Comparado con otras guerras no o sea es
como tú le dices sin aceptable
impensable en nuestros tiempos puedes
vivir algo así y lo estamos jodiendo
Susana al mundo no deja de sorprendernos
Gracias como siempre por estar con
nosotros en directo América frenos 24 un
gran abrazo Susana